Now let's talk about the vehicle display blueprint and how to create a controllable scene.
So first thing we want to do is assign the material to the car mesh.
So open up the display vehicle blueprint by double clicking it in your content browser
and then just select the vehicle mesh on the top left and then plug in the material by
pressing that little arrow there.
And that will essentially assign the material that you've just created to the blueprint.
Next up we'll create a display vehicle blueprint in the construction script here.
So whatever element we plugged our material into we can create a material instance based
on that index.
So if you ended up plugging in your material just into element 0 which was the same for
me on the previous slide so if I just go back to the previous slide I've got material element
0 on my car.
If you've got a different material element so say it's on number 1 or number 2 which
gives you the overall vehicle you need to just make sure this element is updated.
So I'll jump into my editor and show you how to do that.
So with my blueprint open I will go to construction script at the top here.
I will bring in my vehicle mesh so I'm just going to hold down left click and drag out
the vehicle mesh from the component list and then I'm going to create a dynamic material
instance.
So create dynamic material instance.
Again element 0 is going to be my element so just make sure whatever element you've
plugged your material into so if I plugged my material into a different element say the
chassis or the tyre something like this you would update this number inside the blueprint.
So just make sure that you have in the construction script the correct element for your vehicle
selected and then what you can do is you can just drag off here and promote this to a variable.
So drag off the blueprint promote to a variable and call this let's call this I generally
go with the naming convention mi underscore car material but you can name this whatever
you would like.
So that's just created an instance here which we can use later in the tutorial but essentially
this is the main setup.
Now you can override the source material here if you would like because the vehicle has
got the material already assigned you don't necessarily need to plug it in but I mean
even as a backup if you browsed to the material and then plugged it in there that would also
work completely fine.
So you can plug in them just as a backup just to make sure the correct material is assigned
but because the vehicle mesh already has it assigned you should be okay without plugging
that in there.
Next up we're going to add a scalar parameter to the variable that we just created so we
want to create two new variables which are two float variables one called display airspeed
and again you'll see that we are capitalizing each letter and there's no space in the name
but you'll see Unreal Engine creates a space which is really nice and readable and it also
means that we have a nice condensed variable name.
So we've got display airspeed and airspeed total time with this kind of setup I'll jump
into my editor now and show you exactly how to do this but this is the overview if you
want to move forward into the next section.
So inside of Unreal here I'm just going to go to my variables tab I'm going to create
the plus here and we'll call the first one display airspeed and then what we'll do we'll
change the variable type on the top right to a float so we'll call that a float so
it needs to be that green icon there and then we'll press plus again and this one needs
to be called airspeed total time like that and again you'll see that I'm not putting
spaces in my variable names and because I just create a float it creates another float
again which is handy so I'm just going to compile and save just to make sure everything's
okay.
So when I'm dragging out variables I'm going to hold down control on my keyboard and left
mouse drag so it does that.
If I just left mouse drag this out without holding down control I get the option do I
want to get the variable which is what this is or do I want to set the variable which
is what this is.
If I hold down alt and left mouse drag I get the set so it can be a few less button clicks
if you hold down control on your keyboard and drag to get if you hold down alt on your
keyboard to set alternative if I didn't hold down anything on my keyboard I would get the
option get and set so completely up to you what methods you use there but essentially
if I just delete these I want to get the display airspeed so I want that and so from the delta
seconds I just want to multiply this so I'm going to multiply this by pressing the star
key you can alternatively just type multiply and I need to add a additional pin here from
the previous slide the bottom value is going to be 0.1 and I'm going to plug the airspeed
into here so you should have something like this this is a multiply going into the display
airspeed and then what we'll do is we'll add so I'm just going to press plus or you can
type add onto here and we want to get the airspeed total time so I'm holding down control
on my keyboard left mouse dragging so we get this kind of setup here next we want to set
the total time so I'm going to hold alt on my keyboard left mouse drag and let's just
plug that into there so essentially now we've got the variable that we need and now we just
need to set the correct scale parameter on the material so you don't need to click here
but on the construction script we've got this material now where we can edit parameters based
on the material that we created so if I again you don't need to do this but I'm just going to go
and find this in my content browser if I pin this up here I'm going to open up the material and what
I'm looking for is I'm looking for airspeed so you'll see that I have this airspeed value here
and this is the parameter that I want to edit so you'll see airspeed there so I'm just going to
go back into my blueprint so you should be here by now if you didn't follow me down that little
rabbit hole I'm going to stay in my edit graph I'm going to get my material instance so I'm
going to ctrl drag out the material that I created again whatever you named this in your
construction script this is what you're dragging out from the left-hand side I'm going to drag
out the blue pin and say set scalar parameter value and then I'm just going to drag this out
into here and then the value is going to be from this airspeed total time so you can just drag it
into there sometimes I like to double click on the wire and add a little reroute node
alternatively you could just if you don't want wires there do this as well and that would keep
it equally as nice and clean and tidy so the parameter name here as I mentioned is airspeed
and again that airspeed value is just from what we put in our material so whatever you named that
in your material just type in airspeed there and then compile and save and we can move on to the
next section lastly in this section we just want to create a new function which again I'll jump
into the editor and do and so you can follow it step by step but if you know how to create functions
we just want to create a set scalar parameter value and make sure the parameter whatever we
named it whether we named it temperature or temp or whatever you called that parameter in your
material that's essentially what we want to do so we'll send the value to the temp parameter in
the material so let's jump into unreal and break that down for the function so back in our editor
we can see that we've got a function section on the left on the side so I'm just going to click
plus function and I'm going to say set temp again using lower and upper case letters to
differentiate between sets and temp so there's no space here but because I capitalized a T that's
now got a space I'll compile and save just to make sure I always just get into the habit of compiling
and saving as you go so what we want to do here is we want to set a scalar parameter value based
on the material so let's drag out our material again holding down ctrl I'm going to set scalar
parameter by value and if we look at our material again you'll see that we've got this temp here so
whatever you called this a value whether you call it temperature or temp this is what we're looking
for here so I'm going to type in temp also a good practice is sometimes if you've got complex
material parameter names I just click and then click again so it highlights you're going into
the rename you can also hit f2 to rename but I'm going to copy that text paste it in there now it's
quite hard to get temp wrong but if you have complex parameter names sometimes it's good practice
to copy and paste the values in so you know that that's definitely working I'm gonna drag this
variable in here now now what I'm going to do is I'm actually going to do a bit of a shortcut
here so I'm going to get this value I'm going to drag it into here and it creates a new node so
if you drag it into there it creates a new value I'm actually going to call this value temperature
let's see if I can just disconnect this compile save let's try and call it temperature now
so maybe that's not a shortcut maybe this works in yours this has always historically worked for
me maybe doesn't work for some reason but I'm just gonna compile and save I've deleted the
input let's go back to do it the old-fashioned way so I'm gonna select set temperature I'm going
to go to input I'm going to press new input I'm going to type temperature wow it's not working
okay this is super interesting let's call it temp okay so temp seemed to work so maybe it just
doesn't like a certain variable I'm not sure why that is you should be able to type temperature
but if you can let's go with temp which is a good temp name for this let's drop down to make sure
it's a float and now we got our temperature input let's compile save and what I need to do now is I
need to divide this so let's go to the the forward slash key for divide or we can type in divide here
and we just want to divide this variable let's go like that and we just want to divide this by
100 so plug in divide by 100 and then compile and save and that is your function created